bonjour suis dit martinez merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous bonjour secrétaire
général de la cgt on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par jefferson des sports
aujourd'hui personne jour rien ne bouge
ou philippe corti d'être avec nous
jefferson de sud ouest évidemment on va
parler ce qui va se passer dimanche
philippe martinez dimanche sept premiers
mais évidemment avec le traditionnel
défilé du 1er mai quelle sera votre mot
d'ordre quel message ou souhaitait faire
passer à emmanuel macron dimanche ce
qu'on lui fait passer depuis cinq ans et
puisqu'il s'est accéléré d'ailleurs dans
durant cette campagne électorale il ya
premièrement la question des salaires
la question les questions d'emploi et de
la qualité de l'emploi et puis les
questions autour de la sécurité sociale
de la santé des retraites avec
évidemment en filigramme les questions
environnementales voyez un programme
dense mais qui est les sujets principaux
qui concerne les citoyens de ce pays et
notamment le monde du travail justement
sur le monde du travail philippe
martinez emmanuel mâcon dans sa campagne
s'est engagé en faveur du plein emploi
ce défilé du 1er mai intervient dans un
contexte de baisse du chômage nouvelle
baisse du chômage est ce que ça va dans
le bon sens
les chiffres montrent une baisse du
chômage après fo et gratter les chiffres
c'est gelé 10 et quelle qualité de
l'emploi ce qu'on voit c'est que la
précarité augmente et d'ailleurs
faudrait savoir quelqu'un qui travaille
une journée dans un mois n'est plus
considéré comme un demandeur d'emploi ce
qui est vrai mais est ce qu'on peut
vivre avec un salaire d'une journée par
mois ça c'est une vraie question les cdd
les intérims les petits boulots comme on
dit augmente la deuxième chose c'est et
vous le savez il ya une réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui a renforcé les
contrôles des privés d'emploi alors
qu'elles contrôlent bien sur un an les
radiations augmenté de 41% c'est sûr que
quand on dégage des chiffres du chômage
les demandeurs d'emploi les chiffres
baissent donc oui ces cosmétiques non je
dis que les chiffres sont justes mais il
faut aller regarder derrière les
chiffres vous savez très bien que la
précarité augmenté et que
la réforme de l'assurance chômage a fait
en sorte que de nombreux chômeurs sont
sortis des chiffres c'est normal que ça
baisse et puis il ya toujours ce
problème c'est que près d'un chômeur sur
deux n'est pas indemnisée on nous a dit
la vieille rengaine les feignants il
profite du ca mais ça un chômeur sur
deux n'est pas indemnisée mais cette
réforme va venir et pendant cette
réforme doit continuer de l'assurance
chômage elle doit continuer non non nous
on demande qu'elle soit supprimée c'est
un engagement des macros là encore dans
sa campagne
ce qui prouve qu'ils écoutent
est ce que ça veut dire justement pour
vous c'est aussi ça le message que vous
allez
dans la rue aujourd'hui évidemment et le
1er mai est une occasion exceptionnelle
s'est dit défilé traditionnel oui c'est
tous les ans le premier mais ça c'est
sûr mais à une semaine après l'élection
du président macron il ya besoin de
manifestations de masse pour réaffirmer
les exigences sociales
il est tout à fait exceptionnel oui il
est tout à fait exceptionnel parce que
il faut pas que les discours de campagne
se transforment en actes contraires à ce
qu'on a pu percevoir est ce que tout le
monde a perçu dans le vote des citoyens
qui pour une part importante n'ont pas
adhéré au projet du président de la
république mais ont plutôt évité
l'élection de sa concurrente en voici un
vote de rejet
une grande partie de ce vote n'est pas
un vote d'adhésion pour un programme
mais plutôt un vote de rejet de la
concurrente et qu'on nous refasse pas le
coup et surtout le président macron qui
nous a faits en 2017 rappelez-vous il
considérait que à l'époque c'était 66%
était d'accord avec son projet je pense
qu'il faut faire preuve d'humilité
d'ailleurs je lui répète assez souvent
vous y avez parlé depuis dimanche non
des rencontres je vais pas frapper à la
porte de l'elysée pour demander
qu'il avait entendu il nous refait le
coup de la concertation il faut que
j'écoute et s'éteindre renouveler idier
qu'est ce que vous attendez de sa non
mes méthodes choix je sais pas combien
de fois il l'a dit ça à chaque fois
qu'il ya une crise sociale que ce soit
le mouvement des retraites les gilet
jaune il a dit j'ai changé il faut que
j'écoute donc c'est une rengaine qu'on
connaît il faut passer de la parole aux
actes donc moi j'attends les actes sur
le sur le plan de politique philippe
martinez ce 1er mai la gauche pourrait
en profiter pour s'afficher unie lors ce
défilé voulait météo philippe martinez
si l'union de la gauche c'est fait le
1er mai est traditionnellement une fête
internationale de lutte des travailleurs
et des travailleuses
le mouvement social d'une façon large
moi je me félicite qui est un front
assez large des syndicats qui appellent
le problème est aussi des associations
des ong environnementales les partis
politiques qui participent tous les ans
mais à ce n'est pas le défilé des partis
politiques dont qui seront présents mais
comme d'habitude à l'arrière du cortège
de la place comme tous les ans il y aura
un défilé unitaire de la part des
syndicats où ça sera chacun que
l'unité est large puisque il ya
solidaires fsu l'unsa qui participent ce
qui n'est pas habituel dans la majorité
des territoires et des départements
force ouvrière sera présente je crois
que secrétaire général de force ouvrière
sera présent à paris voilà on voit et
puissent des ong des associations donc
je pense que c'est vraiment il faut un
1er mai exceptionnel en termes de
mobilisation parce que il faut rappeler
tout au président de la république et au
futur gouvernement toutes les exigences
qui existe encore ça sera exceptionnel
si à combien de personnes quel est votre
objectif
dimanche je me serais satisfait à
quelqu'un plus il ya de monde
moi je suis pas ni statisticiens
combien le maximum vous savez bien qu'on
est dans une période de congés scolaires
et parfois
entre la manif et les vacances mais en
tout cas il faut du monde il faut que le
message faut pas que la patronne retombe
c'est ça le message tout cas le
président révue annoncé vouloir
transformer pôle emploi en france
travaillent à philippe martinez que ça
vous inquiète c'est une réforme sur
laquelle vous serez forcément consulter
en tout cas vous serez vigilant mais
président de la république a l'habitude
de changer le nom pour nous faire croire
qu'il va y avoir du changement ce qu'il
faut pour l'emploi c'est premièrement
renforcer les effectifs il ya eu
beaucoup de suppressions d'emplois
certains d'agents de pôle emploi on leur
a détourné leur mission par exemple pour
contrôler l es chômeurs c'est pas leur
mission en mission n'est pas de
contrôler les privés d'emploi c'est leur
trouver du boulot il faut renforcer les
effectifs et donc ce que pour l'emploi
joue vraiment son rôle voilà il n'ya pas
besoin d'aller sur des sites privés pour
trouver du boulot on a des agents
compétents qui doivent pouvoir faire
leur boulot convenablement mais c'est
contre 7 serait habillage de pôle emploi
mais oui vous avez trouvé le bon terme
il suffit pas de changer le costume oui
vous ne disiez tout à l'heure que le
chef de l'état qu'elle est le premier
acte
il y en a plusieurs mais je crois que le
sujet principal qui d'ailleurs suscite
de nombreux conflits sociaux c'est la
question des salaires on est dans un
pays de bas salaires le smic par exemple
va augmenter au 1er mai alors c'est pas
un geste généreux du gouvernement c'est
un calcul automatique
eh bien ça va faire que dans une branche
par exemple qui a été beaucoup évoqué
durant là que vit de tout cas fait cafés
hôtels restaurants commerces c'est les
fameux premières deuxièmes lignes bien
avec cette augmentation du smic toutes
les conventions collectives dépendant de
cette branche vont les minimes avons
repassé en dessous du smic
il faut autre chose comme politique
salariale on parle de de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre mais une des premières causes
de cette pénurie c'est l'attractivité
des métiers et notamment sur les
questions salariales donc il faut nous
nous ce que nous avons proposé déjà
depuis longtemps que le smic augmente
vous avez une proposition à 2000 euros
mais qu'à chaque fois que le smic
augmente il ya une loi qui permette que
tous les minima tous les minima branche
suivent il n'y a pas besoin de négocier
pour respecter la loi la loi avec
l'augmentation suite à l'augmentation
évidemment sinon certains vont attendre
trois mois six mois le temps qu'on fasse
des négociations pour voir les minima de
branche
évoluer dans une langue médiate pour
vous ça ça doit faire partie des
priorités
exactement puis après il faut des
négociations dans les branches
évidemment parce que quand on enlève le
plancher si on n'augmente pas le plafond
et tous les étages et grosse conne la
tête philippe martinât sur cette
question du smic jean luc mélenchon
propose un smic à 1400 euros net vous
dites 2000 euros donc la france a
soumise est loin du compte le smic au
savoir de quoi on parle le smic c'est le
salaire qu'ils payent un salarié dont la
qualification n'est pas reconnue par un
diplôme on est tous qualifiés mais tout
le monde n'a pas de diplôme et ben c'est
le sait la base c'est la première ligne
en haut de votre fiche de paye après il
ya toute une série de primes etc qui
fait le salaire brut
avec des cotisants et ensuite on déduit
des cotisations sociales parce que c'est
important les cotisations sociales et ça
donne
le salaire net donc la base le brut le
net nous on agit sur la première ligne
et je pense que c'est important de
parler comme ça parce que la question
des cotisations sociales ça a été
beaucoup évoqué durant cette campagne
ceux qui veulent veulent augmenter les
salaires en supprimant les cotisations
sociales s'est il nous donne d'une main
ce qu'ils nous ont pitié de l'autre et
comment on finance la sécurité sociale
si on paye plus il ya plus de
cotisations sociales voilà des vrais
sujets
salaire ça on a bien compris votre
demande sur le pouvoir d'achat ce qui a
une autre mesure que vous attendez le
salaire c'est essentiel donc occupons
nous de l'essentiel il ya là le dégel du
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires qui
est promis pour l'été ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle oui oui mais à quel niveau ça
fait 12 ans qu'il est gelé il faudrait
les classes elles ont conduit les glaces
et leur augmentation du point de combien
on limonest minimum 10% 10% minimum
minimum 10% pour commencer à rattraper
non seulement la hausse des prix mais le
retard accumulé depuis 12 ans là aussi
c'est un vrai sujet les services publics
on a loué à juste titre la place des
services publics mais ça devient peau de
chagrin il ya beaucoup de zones rurales
mais pas que des zones rurales des
banlieues où quand il ya moins de
services municipaux moins de
fonctionnaires de l'état eh bien il faut
ça complique la vie des gens et je crois
que là aussi ça s'est ressenti dans le
vote aux élections de présidentielle
juste martin espère que vous avez quelle
confiance en emmanuel macron vous l'avez
connu à bercy vous l'avez connu à
l'elysée vous allez retrouver alizés il
ya beaucoup de lois qui arrive en tout
cas beaucoup de demande de votre part
c'est quoi votre indice de confiance
dans le président réélu et c'est pas une
question de confiance il faut qu'il
arrête de parler de promettre et qu'ils
agissent mais pour l'instant voyez quand
à la veille du premier tour on parle
l'allongement de la retraite à 65 ans la
qualité d'écouté du président la
république me semble limité quand on
sait que 74% des français ne souhaitent
pas cette mesure il est revenu un peu
dans l'entre-deux tours sur la question
et encore
boulot j'étais plus sérieuse est prêt à
discuter quand même de cette réforme
pour l'allongement de l'âge de retraite
est ce que c'est ce que vous êtes prêts
à discuter sur la base est la promesse
et
710 confiance à vue parce que je suis
souvent venu vous en parlait ici nous
avons passé deux ans à discuter des
retraites deux ans donc et les choses
sont claires nous refusons tout
allongement de l'âge de la retraite
occupons nous proposons même qu'elle
revienne à 60 ans occupons nous d'abord
premièrement de tous ceux qui après 55
ans et c'est une majorité ne sont plus
au travail plutôt au cul pour nous de se
faire partir les plus anciens pour
laisser la place aux jeunes voilà des
choses concrètes et sur l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation parce que c'est
ça qui ce jeu c'est une réforme des
manuels mâcon est ce que ça vous dit il
faut continuer à allonger la durée de
cotisation mais il veut quatre mois par
an - ont dit non même ça il faut arrêter
il faut faire rentrer plus de
cotisations donc il faut mettre plus de
gens au boulot oui il faut augmenter les
salaires parce que quand les salaires
augmentent je vous expliquer tout à
l'heure que automatiquement via les
cotisations en groupe c'est important
tâche du salaire il faut arrêter les
politiques d'exonérations de cotisations
notamment pour les très grandes
entreprises il faut alimenter
la sécurité sociale et ce qu'ils
alimentent c'est le paiement des
cotisations donc il n'ya pas besoin
d'allonger la durée de cotisation il
faut faire rentrer des cotisations
mais vous nous avons dénoncé à l'époque
la réforme turron parce que c'est une
façon
ambiguë enfin en tout cas cacher de nous
faire travailler plus longtemps
d'ailleurs c'est la réalité où ça il
faut qu'elle arrête vous savez bien que
une grande partie des salariés sont
obligés de continuer à travailler après
l'âge légal parce que sinon leur pension
est amputé est-ce que vous êtes prêts
aux rapports de force sur l'a7 future
réforme des retraites mais on est non
seulement on est prêt mais la réalité
montre qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu
ya beaucoup de mouvements sociaux
géosites régulièrement les salariés
d'amazon c'est la première fois qu'ils
font grève
pourtant c'est une entreprise où les
conditions de travail sont difficiles il
ya beaucoup de précarité on se fait
virer assez facilement par un employeur
qui respecte peu le code du travail eh
bien ils sont mobilisés pour une
augmentation de salaire donc la
mobilisation les déjà là à ce qu'il faut
c'est l'amplifier la généraliser et le
premier mais j'y reviens là dessus air
est une bonne occasion de tout de suite
dire maintenant il faut des actes mais
en quoi est ce qu'en refusant tout
infléchissement c'est-à-dire toute
discussion sur ce créer la base de la
réforme des retraites d'emmanuel maroc
quelque part vous favorisez pas le
passage en mai pour coup je premièrement
on a beaucoup discuté deux en deux ans
on a connu deux ministres de monsieur
retraites ouais on a un bon de prise de
la santé nous essayons claquant la porte
derrière ça c'est pour on à bout d'un
moment on a dit bon on va vous expliquer
nous notre côté ce qu'on veut donc
pourquoi on discuterait uniquement des
propositions du président de la
république quand 74% des français sont
contre nous on veut discuter aussi ça la
négociation on expose des points de vue
mémé et pire on se comprend on tire des
leçons du passé ça fait plus de deux
décennies qu'on nous dit qu en exonérant
les entreprises de cotisations sociales
ça va mieux allez
faisons le bilan ça va mieux non donc il
faut changer philippe martin est sur le
pouvoir d'achat les prix à la pompe sur
le carburant repartent à la hausse ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'un ce gouvernement qui est en
transition l'avant avant les
législatives
est ce que vous attendez des mesures
particulières avant que la nouvelle
assemblée on a proposé il ya la question
des salaires elle est incontournable rko
tournal mais on prend on a proposé aussi
que sur un certain nombre de produits de
première nécessité ça fait des années
qu'on dit et notamment sur l'énergie et
bien on réduise la tva parce que la tva
est un impôt injuste une composition de
marine le pen n'ont ramené de 20 à 5 %
sur je vous dis que ça fait des années
qu'on demande ça je sais que il ya une
tendance au rassemblement national
d'essayer de reprendre des slogans des
syndicats et notamment de la cgt pour
faire croire aux citoyens qu'on et
social mais ma vous le savez bien marine
le pen propose de supprimer les
cotisations sociales pour voile n'est
pas social canton mais je viens de vous
dire qu'il fallait pas supprimer les
cotisations sociales que sase et
plusieurs décennies qu'on faisait ça que
le medef est d'accord que le patronat
est d'accord pour semur donc derrière
les slogans d'ailleurs derrière la vitre
il faut aller regardiez dans l'arrière
boutique et dans l'arrière boutique ce
sont c'est un programme libéral
puisqu'on parle
des conséquences a déjà des conséquences
sur le pouvoir d'achat des français et
notamment sur la question des prix de
l'alimentaire vous êtes favorable aux
sanctions économiques envers la russie
est ce que vous redoutez quand même un
impact fort sur le porte monnaie des
français et il existe déjà
nous sommes favorables à des sanctions
vis-à-vis du du pouvoir russe des
oligarques
pas sur les salariés et d'ailleurs nous
sommes battus dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises pour que les entreprises
françaises se retire de russie mais
qu'elle continue à payer les ouvriers
parce que ils ont rien à voir là dedans
donc oui il faut renforcer les sanctions
mais en même temps ça fait un petit
moment
depuis la crise qu'au but qu'on nous
parle de
réindustrialisation de relocalisation je
trouve que le bilan est maigre là aussi
il ya des belles paroles il faut passer
aux actes si on parle des semi
conducteurs par exemple qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la crise en ukraine et la
guerre en ukraine ça fait un an et demi
que je dis personnellement au ministre
le maire qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya des
entreprises en france qui peuvent faire
ça qu'est ce qui vous dit et bien dit
oui il faut le faire mais ça fait un an
et demi qui se passe rien et je peux
vous citer des tas d'exemples on n'a pas
assez anticipé
la crise due qu'aux villes et les
semi-conducteurs quand les pays
asiatiques sont confinés la chine et
d'autres et que toutes les livraisons
sont bloqués on peut anticiper et puis
on parle beaucoup de la planète mais
vous il faut qu'on réfléchisse aussi on
culpabilise les automobilistes certes et
encore faudra discuter mais quand on
fait fabriquer des produits à l'autre
bout de la planète et qu'on les fait
revenir ça c'est polluant comme en
rêvent mais il est temps qu'on le fasse
plutôt que de continuer à en parler de
nous dire vous avez raison je tends vous
parler d'environnement philippe martinez
emmanuel macron a défini portrait robot
du futur ou la futur locataire de
matignon alors à il ou elle aura à la
fibre environnementale productive et
social ah vous voyez qui s'est pas mon
boulot non mais vous parlez quand même
produit social et environnemental parce
que vous venez de dire ça nous parle
mais ce que je viens de vous dire si on
sait pas vous
c'est pas moi non ça c'est sûr mais ce
que ce que je viens de vous dire c'est
qu'il faut arrêter d'en parler il faut
faire donc c'est pas le nom de du ou de
la future première ministre qui est en
jeu c'est pour quoi faire pourquoi faire
travailler avec elle et
elle a un bilan non elle a un bilan du
potala le bilan du président de la
république donc il faut quelqu'un qui
soit issus du précédent gouvernement bon
c'est pas ça que je vous dis c'est pour
quoi faire est ce que on va augmenter
les serres est ce qu'on va accepter la
loi qu'on propose d'automaticité est-ce
qu'on va refaire des circuits courts est
ce qu'on va réinvestir dans l'industrie
je pense à aux salariés de la sam qui
acquit attendre la démesure pour refaire
repartir leur usine et un gouvernement
français premier actionnaire de renault
qui ne fait rien voilà des sujets
concrets faut arrêter de parler faut
faire j'ai un regret c'est clair le
président de la république irait lui
c'est donc les engagés à relancer cette
filière il ya beaucoup de salariés ça va
c'est quelque chose que vous soutenez il
ya
besoin d'un mix énergétique où on
conjugue nucléaire hydraulique et
renouvelables l e au lien mais c'est
surtout la question quelle entreprise et
vous savez que nous nous militons et
nous nous battons notamment les salariés
d'edf pour une entreprise 100% public un
dernier mot peut-être un peu plus
personnelle fait partie de l on voit un
vous êtes encore dans le combat ils
verrier va laisser sa place à la tête de
force ouvrière dans quelques semaines
vous votre congrès c'est dans un petit
peu moins d'un an vous avez envie de
continuer à écouter on a encore un peu
plus enfin un peu moins d'un an vous à
raison pour y réfléchir
voilà
je suis vous allez senti que j'étais
motivé
hâtif et donc le moment venu on parlera
de ça ça nous on n'est pas dans les
primaires et dans ce qu'on entend un peu
trop je pense que les salariés ils
pensent à autre chose que ma décision
n'est pas prise je reviendrai quand vous
ma vitre et vous avez connu de président
de la république et françois hollande à
emmanuel macron mais oui fin j'en ai
connu d'autres mais j'ai fait passer la
terre général qu'un poisson la cgt merci
beaucoup merci merci d'avoir été floués
évidemment vous ré invitera dans les
prochaines heures
jefferson la une de sud ouest c'est
emmanuel macron macron 2 ce qui va
changer c'est à la une de votre journal
[Musique]